will TR
remember
e
for
[Music]
maybe not
you
k
[Music]
Christian
good evening hello welcome to the table
I am so so glad that you're here tonight
uh my name is Karen Miner and I'm part
of the leadership team uh thank you for
not only making your way here but also
making your way through the foyer um as
you can see there was some some water
damage there and we've got some fans
going and um if you could just be
lifting up Pleasant Valley in prayer as
the
do all of the repairs and figure out
what what else is needed to get things
kind of back to where they were
um uh but you will most likely hear the
fans just know they're doing their job
of cleaning up cleaning up the the mess
in the water um I have a couple of
announcements that I am really excited
about uh first of all it is first Sunday
tonight it is can you believe it's
November
yeah I know it's November yeah it is
hard to believe we're already here uh it
is the first Sunday of November the
first Sunday of every month around here
after the service we meet up at hat
Creek Burger Company in
saxi and it
is yeah and we enjoy dinner together so
it's a great way to meet people in our
community and to just continue the
connections beyond our Sunday service so
we would love for you to join us there
hot Creek tonight it's just down the
road about 5 minutes in
saxi uh secondly next Friday November
10th I believe is uh our Fall Fest and
chili cookoff and we are celebrating All
Things fall and our kids ministry uh
volunteers are hosting a Fall Fest and
chili cookoff that will be at Josh and
Kelly tilford's house in saxi so again
not very far from here and if you would
like more information on that everybody
is welcome it will be very
familyfriendly uh fun games food and of
course chili uh there will be can you
guys put a the QR code up if you want to
scan the QR code you can get more
details about the Fall Fest all like
what time it is the address there's also
a Sign Up Genius you can sign up to
bring your chili if you think it's good
enough uh drinks uh snacks anything like
that would be very much appreciated um
so again the Fall Fest is coming up this
Friday hope you can make it it will be
super fun and I think the weather is
going to be great uh and then
thirdly uh on this first week in
November four years ago so back in
2019 the table officially became a
church yeah yeah I know so we are
celebrating four years at the table and
for those of you that weren't with us
back in
2019 that was four months before
everything shut down for the pandemic
and so we were here in this building for
four months and then we weren't and we
didn't know if if our little Community
would survive that um we were online for
what a good year we were online for a
year um and those were just some we
uncertain times uh and so four years
later I am just so thankful I'm thankful
I'm thankful for you I'm thankful for
Pleasant Valley I'm thankful for what
God is doing here and what he's done
here uh to bring us all together and to
help the table continue because I truly
believe our mission and values are
needed especially in this in this area
so why don't we take a moment just to
Center
ourselves um you can close your eyes if
you want to take some deep breaths if
that's helpful for you
um and you know with everything going on
in the world gosh just
Wars
um that is heavy on my heart lately
um keeping that just on our hearts and
in our prayers and then also making room
and space for
gratitude for someone you're grateful
for something you're grateful
for just take some
breaths and meditate on what you are
thankful
for God thank you so much for tonight
thank you for this place and these
people here in the sanctuary as well as
those who are joining us online thank
you for their very
lives thank you for their hearts thank
you for how you've made them God each
one a beloved child of
yours and God I pray that um the music
the
message the
[Music]
people that those things would bless our
hearts wherever we find ourselves
tonight and that would we would be
reminded of how much you love us
God how interconnected we are with your
creation and with
humanity and that we would extend that
gratitude out and extend those blessings
out to
others so God help us to Center on you
tonight and be reminded of of who you
are in your
goodness I'm so thankful for
that in Jesus name
amen welcome everyone why don't you go
ahead and
stand we are so glad to have you here
it's it's uh how many of you enjoyed one
more hour of sleep did that change
anyone else's life sure changed mine but
we're really glad to have you here we're
going to go ahead and start with some
[Music]
worship Stakes
what looks to me like weakness is a
canvas for your strength my story isn't
over my story's just
begun failure won't Define me that's
what my father does fair you won't
Define me that's what my father does
oo lay your burdens down
oo here in the father
house Che shame at the
door
anymore you're in the father's
[Music]
house arrival is not the end game the
Journey's where you are you never want
it perfect you is the one in my heart
and the story isn't over if the story
isn't good enough failures never when
the father's in the room I said fail's
never when the father's in the room wo
wo lay your burdens down wo
wo here in the father's house check your
shame at the door it ain't welcome
anymore wo
wo you're in the father's
[Music]
house prodal come home helpless find
Hope Love Is On The Move when the
father's in the room prison do sing wide
dead come to life Love Is On The Move
when the father's in the
room Miracles take place cynical Find
Faith love is breaking through when the
father's in the
room J's walls are quaking strongholds
now are
shaking love is breaking through when
the father's in the room yeah yeah love
is breaking through when the father's in
the room wo
wo lay your burdens down wo
wo here in the father's house check your
shame at the door it a welcome anymore
wo you're in the father's
house you're in the father's
house
no shame
[Music]
here all right kids are dismissed please
go through those two
doors and I will get it started on the
prayer of the people you guys can um
read this along with me but before we
get started on the prayer of the people
um and I'm just so glad to be here today
it's been a few weeks I've been um my
wife and I and our our son is in the
marching band so we've been super busy
with that last couple weeks and um
season's over um and while that was a
fun and blessed time um I I so glad to
be back here with y'all so anyways let's
go ahead and start on this prayer if you
guys will read with
me for the city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
good Good Earth you've given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the the vulnerable
the marginalized and those unjustly
targeted for their gender sexuality race
or other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to
you
[Music]
for the names and the moments we have
spoken aloud and those we have kept in
our hearts we pray to you that they may
have life and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
Amen Let the king of my heart be the
mountain where I run
the fountain I drink from oh he is my
song Let the king of my heart be the
shadow where I hide the ransom for my
life oh he is my song you are good
you're
good
oh you are good you're
[Music]
oh let the king of my heart be the wind
inside my CS
the anchor in the we oh he is my
song Let the king of my heart be the
fire inside
my the echo of
my he is sing that again let the king of
my heart the wind inside
my the anchor in the wav
oh he is my
song Let the king of my heart be the
fire inside my vein the echo of my days
oh he is my song you are good you're
good
oh you are good you're
oh yes you are good you're
good
oh you are good you're
oh you're never going to let you're
never going to let me
down you're never going to let you're
down you're never going to let me you're
never going to let me
down you're never going to let you're
down
you're never going to let you're never
going to let me down you are good you're
good
oh yes you are good you're
good you are good you're
good
oh you are good you're
good oh
you're never going to let you're never
going to let me
down you're never going to let you're
never going to let me
never going to let me you
are
oh you are good you're
good
[Music]
oh
I love
[Music]
you though your mercy never
fails and all my
days I've been H in
your from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my head
I will see of the goodness of
God all my
life all my life you have been
faithful all my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I am
a I will
of the goodness of
God I love your
voice you have led me through the
fire in darkest night you were close
like no
other I've known you as a
father I've known you as a
friend I
in the
goodness of
God my life you have been
[Music]
faithful my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
am I will see the goodness of God your
goodness your goodness is running after
is running after
me your goodness is running after it's
running after me with my life laid down
I'm surrendered now I give you
everything your goodness is running out
is running after me your
goodness your goodness is running after
it's running after
me your goodness is running after is
running after me with my life laid down
I Surrender now I give you
everything your goodness is running
after it's running after me
[Music]
my life you have been
faithful my life you have been so so
good every breath
I I will sing
of the goodness of
God I will
s of the
goodness of
God lord Jesus I'm so
glad that your goodness is not something
we have to chase after or
find that your goodness is not some kind
of treasure hunt
so much of life feels like something
we're having to work for
constantly something we have to find
something we have to be better
for something we have to prove that we
deserve but by your grace your goodness
is not that your love is not
that in fact it's the other way
around your goodness is running after us
your love is chasing after
us Jesus help us to stop
running help us to turn around and face
your goodness face your
love we ask this in your name
amen if you guys want to turn to each
other and say an awkward hello and you
can even turn to somebody and say this
is awkward and then find your seat
well Grace and
peace it is so good to be with you so so
good um my name is Brett and uh a joy a
joy to welcome you and um as always that
includes those joining us online love
youall Lots you're not forgotten and and
um anyone here tonight who is new uh
thank you so much for being with us
being Among Us um so we are in the midst
of a series right now um let's see I
think this is part five yeah um next
week if I remember correctly will'll be
our our last one in the series um but uh
it's titled the Bible doesn't say that
and it's we've been just kind of
covering these little turns of phrase
you know that are like in the culture um
sometimes in church culture sometimes
it's even in the just broader like
Western American culture um that like
sound like they're in the Bible you know
but they're nope they're not and as
we've been making our way through for
those who have been with us you probably
notice like it's it's not
well I would say most of them have
turned out to be pretty bad like pretty
bad theologically not not awesome um but
mostly it's been in the kind of
interpretation and application of them
probably like any cliche it's like it
gets kind of watered down down it gets
we you know used in weird ways and and
such um but there's usually like some
kernel of Truth you know in them and uh
so I I think tonight the probably the
one we're doing tonight is like of all
of them I think it would be the most
like old-fashioned like I'm not sure if
some of the teenagers in the room will
have heard this phrase um so I don't
know maybe I'm showing my age by
including it in the series but it's the
Lord helps those who help themselves um
I think most I'm seeing some nodding
heads so I don't know some of you um any
do you recognize this like is this this
phrase you've heard at all no M's saying
no so I don't I think I must be getting
old because I'm like yeah you know this
popular
phrase they're like never heard it um so
but it is it's an interesting one um
kind of theologically we'll we'll get
kind of more into it I did want to frame
tonight though with our um by reading
our scripture which will return to as
we've often done we've kind of done sort
of a historical cultural analysis of the
thing and then we get back in the
scripture you know about Midway through
and that'll be the same tonight but I
want to kind of be in your in your mind
so this is um Matthew 16 24- 27 uh it
says then Jesus said to his disciples
whoever wants to be my disciple must
deny themselves and take up their cross
and follow me for whoever wants to save
their life will lose it but whoever
loses their life for me will find it
what good will it be for someone to gain
the whole world and yet forfeit their
soul or what can anyone give in exchange
for their soul it's a good question you
know like why why are we making this
trade and yet we do for the son of man
is going to come in his father's Glory
with his angels and then he will reward
each person according to what they have
done so let's go um back in time a
little bit the year it's
1859 in a man with the most wonderful of
names Samuel
Smiles wrote a book this has got to be a
pin name I'm assuming I don't maybe not
um if if not this man like his name was
his Destiny because he wrote one of the
first books that has now kicked off an
industry which is worth billions of
dollars and and it's probably it's like
the most
American of all movements ever
um so the book he wrote in 1859 was
titled self-help with illustrations of
character and
conduct and um this is the opening this
is like the opening words of chapter one
you can go find it on Google books which
is how I like found this book it's so
great um he says this Heaven helps those
who help
themselves is a well-tried Maxim
embodying in a small Compass the results
of last Human Experience the spirit of
self-help is the root of all genuine
growth in the individual and exhibited
in the lives of many it constitutes the
true source of national Vigor and
strength you can tell he's this is from
1859 you know National Vigor and
strength he says help from without in
other words outside of ourselves is
often infeeling in its effects but help
from
within invariably
invigorates so poetic um so he like
kicks off the self-help
industry and um so fast forward this
like 150 years like where has all of
this kind of movement gone um I want to
name uh someone his name is Tim Ferris
anyone know Tim Ferris so um fairly
popular podcaster he fairly early on the
podcasting B bandwagon so he has one of
the more popular podcasts like in the
world now um and he's also uh an author
in the it's really like it's not even
just self-help now it's it's known as
the um like the Quantified Self movement
so it's this idea of like um
maximizing
everything about you it's very like data
driven so you you take you know if it's
if you're going to get into like the
health side of things then it's like um
analyzing certain metrics and getting
your blood work done and do you know
it's just like a scientific approach to
like every aspect of your life like if
you're going to date no don't just date
like a normal human being like figure
out how to do it in the most efficient
and productive way ever uh try to figure
out how you can go on 150 dates of five
minutes a piece in three weeks you know
it's just like the most insane kind of
it's just taking the self-help movement
and just pushing it out to its most like
ridiculous fascinating extremes you can
see this in the language of feris um the
titles of his books the 4our work week
um the
4our body the 4our chef right and it's
all about timing um because it's it's
about right
maximizing your time and energy and
efficiency and you know how to get them
how to kind of squeeze them most out of
every ounce of your productive life is
anyone getting anxious just as I
described you're like oh my gosh it
sounds like my job you
know um I think where this kind of
movement has gone if I had to sum it up
like in one question it would be it that
this movement asks how how can I cram
more things into my day like that's sort
of the thing you know what I mean like
how to just maximize every ounce of who
you are and it's sort of ironic that
Ferris wrote like the four-hour work
week because the man has never worked
four hours only a week in his life like
he works like you know is a workaholic
um so that's sort of and that's kind of
where this goes right it's not like you
take the time saved and then relax and
just be you know no no you take the time
say it's sort of like how people I
imagine um um back before washing
machines and we thought boy if we could
just have a a washing machine it would
save us so much time I mean just imagine
we're here we are scrubbing these
clothes takes hours a week boy if I
could just take that time saved I'd just
relax you know but what do we all do no
like we take the time saved and we just
keep on going you know what I mean like
we use it to get more efficient and
slightly crazy and so it seems to me
that kind of however Old Samuel smiles
um intended the the self-help movement
um and whatever he meant by opening his
book with the phrase Heaven helps those
who help themselves um I think this was
kind of its inevitable end game there
was just this massive this emphasis on
like the thinking problem solving
analyzing mind to the almost total
neglect of
like all of the wonderful things that
make us
human um what we'll talk about in a
moment kind of our inner world like I'm
thinking of you know um intuition and
emotion and feeling and um Artistic
Endeavors and spirituality and religion
you know it's sort of like that side of
life just gets like well all that's not
very efficient you know and so it just
sort of gets
shelv um but I bring up Ferris though um
very much on purpose because um to to
his credit he I mean he's been around
like quite a while in the public eye for
good probably pushing 20 years and he
has um he's really started to
Pivot and for example he's opened up
about the fact that while he was this
hard driving college student going to
Princeton like full ride scholarships
and straight A you know um at that same
time he was struggling with suicidal
ideation
um which of course did not make its way
into his early books you know um
throughout his life he has struggled or
struggled with um bipolar disorder um
with major depressive
episodes and again early in his life
that none of that was making it through
you know what I mean um because that's
all sort of that
messy inner World stuff you know heart
and mind like that's just sort of has to
be Shel you know but to his credit
he's really I think I think because he
pushed it sort of he took Samuel Smiles
inside and just pushed it out as far as
he could go and
realized
um it's it's sort of an
empty thing you know just to be like
what's the purpose of life just getting
more efficient you know like somehow
that sort of like to what
end where is this going um I found an
interview um just from recent years with
um Tim Ferris in uh in GQ Magazine um
actually before I read that let me read
another quote this is um a quote by a
writer named adanti um and he's
describing modern culture so let me let
me read this first adish Shanti says
this so many today are tied and bound to
themselves that they cannot stop running
from here to there and Back Again always
on the lookout for something more
different or better they cannot see that
they are getting nowhere
at all I love this closing line and they
are getting
nowhere
faster and faster with all the more
Ingenuity all the time I mean is that
not just the perfect summation you know
of so much modern living like we don't
know exactly where we're going or why we
need so desperately to get there but boy
we're going to get there very quickly
you know um so with this in mind this I
want to come back to to feris um and he
says this it it doesn't matter how much
money you have it doesn't matter how
effective or efficient you are it
doesn't matter what types of fancy toys
you collect it doesn't matter how hot
your significant other is if your inner
World your internal monologue or
dialogue is that of anger or despair or
frustration or sadness the majority of
the
time almost none of these other things
matters very much and then he goes on to
point out out how you can't wield money
or time even effectively you can't
deepen relationships repair
relationships deescalate instead of
escalate conflict unless you have a
certain degree and then he just kind of
starts throwing out words because I
think he's sort of grasping with what is
this whole inner World thing um so it's
a little vague what he's getting at but
he just says without some a certain
degree of self-awareness emotional
resilience emotional acceptance um I
think Ferris is really um he's turned to
sto ISM as kind of his religion I I I
wish he would maybe do that plus some
other I really yeah I think you could
really benefit um from from The Riches
of say like the Christian contemplative
tradition that wants to talk all about
everything feris is hinting at there
like he's reached the end of himself
right and I think this is the thing with
this sort of you know Heaven helps those
who help themselves like if I were to
interpret that in the most positive
sense it could be you know well the Lord
invites us into the process okay well
that's fine that's what you mean by that
well then yeah sure but often you know
you take that though like the way Samuel
Smiles use it and that's how I think
most of American culture has used it
with this sort of almost a practical
atheism you know the Lord helps those
who helps themselves AKA I've got to do
this if anything's going to happen I've
got to be the one to do it and so so I'm
going to buckle down and I'm going to
make it happen in my life you know I
mean it's this sort of I'm going to take
the reins of my life and I'm going to
run and hopefully God's kind of with me
or something you know but like you can
can you see where that's like that's the
spirit of this phrase and I think
there's um it's a bit taken just in this
sense it's just like a dead
end and so when people say the Lord
helps those who help themselves what
they seem to have in mind is a whole way
of being
that is so focused on the outward it's
focused on outward forms of success and
self-improvement to the almost total
neglect of the inward journey of the
heart does that make sense where um yeah
it's almost like we we got this I don't
know this sort of American Dream thing
going but the American dream it wasn't
to become a person of such great peace
and love just following Jesus with all
my heart you know it's like no we're
that we're like I want a big house like
that's you know often the dream you know
I would like at least two fancy
vacations a year you know like what are
we what are we doing it's I mean and
Ferris has done it he's got he's
multi-millionaire everything you could
want and you what did he find at the end
of that Journey like something's off
with
me which brings us um back to our our
scripture and I've underlined a few
phrases that I want us to meditate on
tonight that Jesus said to his disciples
whoever wants to be my disciple must
deny themselves take up their cross
follow me for whoever wants to save
their life will lose it but whoever
loses their life for me will find it
what good will it be for someone to gain
the whole world can you hear Fair bares
Samuel Smiles kind of thing you know to
gain the whole
world and yet forfeit their soul what
can anyone give an exchange for their
soul for the son of man's going to come
in his father's Glory with his angels
and then he will reward each person
according to what they have done so I
underline a few of these phrases deny
themselves save their life gain the
whole world reward each person according
to what they have done let's walk
through some of the
um deny themselves I wonder how that
hits us especially maybe in American
culture where it's sort of all about
like I just want to fulfill myself you
know that maybe this I don't know just
sounds really um sad um or something um
but I don't think it's like in the sense
of you know do you have something you
enjoy in your life well stop it you know
that's unchristian or you know like I
like dark chocolate well no more dark
chocolate for you you must deny yourself
to be you know I think that's a sort of
surfacy reading of of this um I think
it's actually much deeper and um and
more profound than that I I Think Jesus
is inviting us
to say no
to certain parts of our self that we
think are our it's like our best friend
but is actually our worst enemy like
those parts those kind of ego Ren um
comparison
obsessive uh
competitive sort of surface self that
Restless mind self that's constantly
seeking to as Jesus says gain the whole
world like just once it once it all that
kind of
um acquisitive sort of greed but I don't
just mean in the sense of like money you
know it's it's a it's a kind of grasping
um and clinging to life this part of us
that wants this outward external
success um but again those dreams how
this looks it tends to be very
consumeristic very materialistic in our
culture and
so it it ends up being so empty and and
so it seems I think this is what Jesus
is actually inviting us to I mean it's
quite startling um but in a sense to die
to
um I'm curious I would be interested in
some of your small group discussions
this week on how this language hits you
because I just think for us as Americans
this is like very difficult partly
because we are so self-help oriented and
it's sort of like a national virtue to
be like posit positive you know what I
mean and just always Chasing the Dream
you know and so when someone sort of
calls the dream into question it's
incredibly deflating you know what I
mean like it's like you're taking the
wind right out of our sails like this is
the whole purpose of our life you know
um but I think the the point is that
actually um Jesus Jesus has something
better for
us that as we die to
that it's like our life actually
begins Joy actually begins because
what's it all about as Ferris named it's
it's
about right it's it's who we are on the
inside it's it's um the the spirit of
God filling us it's a surrender to Jesus
in every aspect of our living it's it's
um maybe one way we might say it is it's
it's not so much about how
self-helpy-ness utterly like lose
yourself in a sense just doing a thing
making a thing helping
someone like where you're not even
focused on you know like well how am I
getting along here how am I is this are
my goals happening am I moving towards
the you know I mean like you're not even
focused on the self but it's it's this
utter surrender this this deep letting
go I think this is what Christ is
inviting us into
to
um the way we might sum it up is to say
Western culture is trying endlessly to
improve our ego-driven competitive small
self Christianity is an invitation to
die to that self so that and this is key
so that we can come
alive to our deep self hidden with
Christ in God as Jesus talked about
there at the end he says and and you'll
be rewarded for what you've done or how
you've lived um those rewards of of
course is it's not about like how much
square footage you have on your home or
the amount in your
401k or how many fancy vacations you got
you know what what is it it's it's about
how um in christed we
were how how
um filled with the spirit of God we were
how much joy we lived
with like that will be the
thing I um preached a kind of similar
I'll close this story I preached a kind
of a similar message um at my last
Church community and um the the message
there was like different language but
similar idea was it was the idea of
American Western culture is all about
onward and
upward but God's invitation to us is
downward and
inward which is a hard message you know
um although I think it actually aligns
well with life which you know because
while we have our sort of dreams of my
life's just gonna every day and every
way get better and better you know and
it's like but the invit like actual
living though is like oh a little
challenging uh it like takes us down you
know so anyway so I preached this
message and a Gentleman he's kind of on
the edges of our community though I got
to know him pretty good we had been out
for coffee he'd invited my wife and I
over for dinner with his family so so we
like I knew him pretty well you know um
but
he came up to me after that sermon he
didn't usually give me feedback but he
told me after I preached that message
he's like I'll be honest that was a my
for
me and I was like oh okay you know I
mean I'm fairly used to people like
usually they email me um you know there
their thoughts which is fine um but I
was kind of like Curious like oh oh okay
he's like yeah yeah that it just it was
it so
depressing and I was like oh interesting
all right well that that's fine you know
I'm sorry it was depressing but I I hope
you could maybe see the the goodness in
or I don't know I just tried to kind of
played off you know I wasn't trying to
like get into a big discussion with him
right there in front of every um but
then years later well and I should name
this gentleman wonderful guy um but like
very very onward and upward kind of guy
very self-help kind of guy you know what
I mean like outwardly tall handsome
beautiful family successful career big
house I mean just like every just
knocking out of the park just amazing
you know um but years later I lost lost
touch with him years later I
heard that um his marriage had dissolved
he was struggling the whole time he
attended our community with like deep
alcoholism
um and there was some abuse and such in
the in the
family and I
was I was shocked you know but not but
not you know what I mean because and I
don't tell the story to like can you
believe that horrible no actually I
resonate with his story in the sense of
I feel like that's what American culture
sets us up to do that's what the Lord
helps those who help themsel you know
it's just what it sets us up to do to
present to look at me I'm a winner you
know when the whole whole time the truth
is so much more complicated than that is
it not for every single one of us like
even at our greatest moment of success
we're like haunted by fears of failure
you know I mean like we're just human
beings
and I so wish he could have seen the
like Beauty in the invitation of what
Jesus is inviting him
into like inviting him into the
vulnerability inviting him into the
realness the
honesty with like his actual
Journey with his his journey to die to
himself so that he could come
alive and so I don't know if maybe you I
certainly hear myself in his story maybe
you see yourself in a bit of his story
um I don't tell it to be like depressing
this message isn't meant to be
depressing um although it might be you
mean sometimes we have to feel the
weight of things before we can start to
break through you know um so I'll just
close with this I'll say if you're still
breathing and presumably you all are
then um it is not too
late to follow Christ it is not too late
to say you know what I want to be real
and authentic and
true I want to pursue Jesus I want that
um fullness of What the Lord Has for me
um and I just wonder what God could do
with a community of people who are kind
of leaving all of our million
self-improvement projects behind you
know in order to really come alive in
Christ in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood blood of
Christ in the wine uh we do so as a
people in need as a people um kind of
dying some things tonight maybe there's
some things you need to like as you come
forward you need to like let go of these
kind of wish dreams that are like
driving you but you can see like maybe
it's not so healthy maybe these things
need to be surrendered um let this be a
moment to to do that so um the way that
we'll participate tonight we'll just
start with a front row and we'll work
our way back um we practiced what's
called an Open Table meaning if you were
here tonight and you want to participate
then you are absolutely free to do that
um the red is wine the white is grape
juice so you've been warned and um
finally you can just partake whenever
you'd like no one will like lead you
through you know the exact moment some
people take it right away some people
return to their seats and kind of
prayerfully um take it there but um yeah
however you want to come forward um we
would we would love for you to do that
so this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
feel free to take your time there's no
rush but we're going to go ahead and
close with this song uh titled simple
gospel uh some of you may be very
familiar with it some of you may not um
but the reason I chose this song was
because it really speaks to this
dying to self and not going down a path
that is so self-centered and
self-helping I mean I've read so many of
those self-help books and I can't really
hear Tim Ferris is voice much because
it's so annoying to me now
um but this
song This Song speaks to a Simplicity in
our faith in dying to ourselves
and embracing a simple gospel of Christ
so if you feel like you want to you may
stand with us or if you want to sit
there and let it wash over you that's
good but um we're going to sing this
last
one I want to know you
Lord like I know a
friend I want to know you
Lord
I want to know you
Lord like I know a
friend I want to know you
Lord so I'm laying
down all my
religion I'm laying
down I want to know you
Lord I'm laying
down all my
religion I'm laying
down want to know you
[Laughter]
[Music]
Lord
and I used to
think that I could box you
in but I'm laying
down I want to know you
Lord I used to
think I could box
you but I'm laying
down I want to know you Lord
want to know you
Lord want to know you
Lord to know
[Music]
you Lord I've been
told to be
ashamed Lord I've been
told I don't measure
up Lord I've been
told I'm not good
enough but you're here with
me
the reach out and
you find me in
[Music]
the and you say
no of
untruth can
separate
us I reach
out I reach out
and
you find me in the
[Music]
D say no amount of
untruth can
[Music]
separate
us I will
rejoice in the Temple
gospel I will
rejoice in you
Lord I will
rejoice in the simple
gospel I will
rejoice in you
[Music]
Lord
reach
you find me in
the and you say
no of
untruth can step up
[Music]
may we all find some moments this week
where we can just
be especially when that voice in your
head is going well I need to do this I
need to get that done and what about
this just just say sh to yourself and
just be for a moment
thank you so much for being with us
tonight I hope that the service blessed
you right where you are um don't forget
about hat Creek tonight we're going to
head over immediately after the service
um we would love to have you there just
like here your presence here enriches
this community it will do the same
outside of this building at hat Creek so
please please join us um if you need
prayer a hug uh somebody to listen to uh
please come find me after the service I
would love to be there for you however I
can um also if you are new if this is
your first time visiting with us or
maybe second time uh please take a
moment to either uh snap the QR code
they're going to put up on the screen in
a moment uh that has a link directly to
our online visitor form just fill that
out and submit it or we have physical
cards out on the little tiny table out
in the lobby if if you could just write
your name and contact information we
would love to be able to follow up with
you answer any questions you might have
or just say thanks thanks for visiting
with us also um as I mentioned at the
beginning of the service the table has
been around for four years now and the
vision and the values and the mission on
my shirt are something I believe in very
very strongly and my husband and I give
to the table so that this thing called
the table can keep going year after year
this is something that I'm so proud to
just be able
to um give to the Next Generation like
when we started the table I thought
about my kids who are teenagers a church
that they can feel at home in that they
can be themselves in and not all
churches are like that and I'm not
saying the table is all that um in like
a prideful way but like in an inclusive
way the communities like this are needed
and my giving and your giving helps
communities like this to kind of keep
chugging along so if our vision and
values resonate with you uh you can also
use that QR code to give to the table
lastly I would love to send you out into
your night and week ahead with a
benediction which is just a blessing for
the road so if you are able please
stand these are words that were written
for this community specifically these
are words that were meant for you so you
can receive those however you like you
some people like to put out their hands
and a posture to receive some people
like to close their eyes and just let
the words kind of fall over them um or
you can just open your heart wherever
you
are you are a child of
God you are a child of God God this is
true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go with the assurance that you
are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of love and compassion and Grace
to everybody you come in contact with
have a good night be blessed and don't
forget about hat Creek good
[Music]
night and I will
rejoice in the simple
gospel I will rejoice
in you
Lord I will
rejo in the simple
gospel I will
rejoice in
[Music]
you
he